the wild cast of thor love and thunder
certainly had a crazy time filming the
whole movie they had so many favorite
scenes that it seems like they could
have just said the entire thing was
their favorite but for the purpose of
our own enjoyment we've gathered up a
bunch of their favorites and some of
their least favorites we think everyone
can agree though the music choice in
this one was perfect number one the
guardian team up we all dreamed to see
again and one of the best times for
chris hemsworth to be on set that's just
such a joy to work with that crew seeing
the continuation of the squad all the
way back from end game felt like bliss
for chris it felt to him like he was
having a little reunion with some old
classmates and these were the scenes in
love and thunder that thor could really
be himself pairing an offbeat superhero
with a couple of space outcasts what's
the perfect dynamic to open the movie
with number two one may think a
superhero should have epic action
sequences but director taika watiti
believes the character should have
epicness in a different aspect it's got
a great pair of essence the most talked
about scene from the film was chris
hemsworth's stunning nude physique
during thor's encounter with zeus not
that we were gawking or anything but it
was hard not to notice the demigod's
assets i'm very proud of it as well i'm
as proud of his
as he is being that this was a moment
taika really wanted in the film chris
was all too pleased to agree with him
hey chris
asking for a friend what's your method
to get those assets
number three as best buy falls out of
the mainstream its parking lots still
seem to thrive we were literally in a
parking lot with like a blue screen
natalie portman was stunned to walk on
set and see a big blue screen in front
of a best buy she thought where's the
punchline tyka but don't be fooled
natalie he's finding creative things in
the most unsuspecting of places one of
them was beautifully like beautiful
visually scenes i've seen on film this
scene was actually portman's favorite
once she saw how it turned out in the
final cut
number four poor christian bale has a
lot of his favorite scenes cut from this
film one most notable was a lovely
scream he got to do in the moment i did
not see the light of day as much as we
loved the throwbacks to classic music
videos 30 seconds of screaming may have
been a little too much on the audience's
ears
however if this bit isn't included in
the deleted scenes one day the gods will
have to pay for it
number five there are very few scenes in
this thor that the cast found
unfavorable and surprisingly one of the
most iconic moments in the film was
russell crowe's least favorite well
we'll see if i make it through the edit
he seemed a little too chillaxed about
the possibility of having his appearance
cut even though it was just too funny
for us watching his zeus interpretation
from an oscar-winning actor not being
pleased with your performance says a lot
but luckily the director listened to his
heart and kept him in
number six tessa thompson fans will know
that she has a special place in her
heart for goats and now she got to star
alongside two of them we had some we did
some press with a goat a goat actor her
and natalie held no shame in admitting
that they'd pet the prosthetic creatures
between takes and we really couldn't
blame them all that fuzz would turn into
nap time for us real quick but the one
thing portman admitted to and we hate
even saying this is that she got a
little too curious and started feeling
around the goats elsewhere you got
familiar with the time i did
i mean it was like kind of the first
thing i was curious about
number seven a marvel actor loving wire
work preposterous
i loved the wire work that's kind of the
most fun it seems like almost every
marvel actor despises the whole stunting
in the sky but natalie portman loved
being up on those harnesses and telling
jokes at the same time she couldn't
understand why a lot of these moments
were cut in the final edit but rest
assured why td knew what he was doing
and he was not so nice about it
you know if it was cut it's because
it wasn't good enough number eight a
super duo is a great team in films and
in real life that was the case for tessa
thompson and natalie portman who have
been friends for years thompson
expressed a lot of gratitude for being
in those scenes with jane growing as on
and off screen sisters in the process i
think you really get to see valkyrie
um find a sister again and and that is
is exciting her favorite bit was when
valkyrie and jane had that heart to
heart moment a great scene for them
and a wonderful break from all the chaos
for us number nine all that glitters
is not gold to take a water the gold
christian refers to here are the scenes
that he loved so much that were
unfortunately axed by the director
although he doesn't explain them in
detail he talks about them being a very
collaborative experience with taika and
quite possibly pushing the boundaries of
a family-friendly superhero movie he
understood in the end and after a great
debate with the director saying there's
so much gold that's on the cutting room
floor hilarious stuff and creepy stuff
but that was perhaps pushing it to a
realm where maybe it wouldn't have been
able to be family friendly which we
always wanted it to be
number 10 look out hulk we've got a real
life one on set just not filled with
gamma or anything tyga is more than just
a director it seems like he's more of a
hyper child set loose on a blockbuster
production he really enjoyed the scene
where new asgard sits in destruction
because
well he had the freedom to smash pieces
on set keep in mind being the director
of a huge marvel production can cause a
whole lot of stress so it looks like he
smashes set pieces a lot to keep calm
and cool during interviews it's always
good to let off a little steam like that
number 11 this was one of the many
scenes that were cut during the
post-production process
but what makes this one different is
that it was re-added during the final
edit all thanks to tessa the scene
portrays the actors at new asgard
begging valkyrie to put on another show
that doesn't seem like much of a scene
to us but to tessa this scene tugged at
her appreciation for theater strings she
explained her reasoning more saying i
was like that has to be in the movie
having them around to explore the
importance of theater and storytelling
as expressed in asgardian culture i just
loved that
number 12. you'd think a former batman
actor would have no problem with taking
on bigger foes but at the time of
filming love and thunder christian bale
was not embodying the buff batman
physique i'm a lot older than when i
last did any big fight sequences like
that he had just got done filming a
movie in which muscles were not to be
required
so he was just a little smaller than
usual one of his favorite scenes was
getting to face off against thor for the
first time although he found it quite
silly to be much smaller than his
co-star it really doesn't matter at all
with the size difference because bale
was having the time of his life beating
up a demigod
number 13 for the love of thunder let
hemsworth keep his shirt on we know a
lot of fans have no problem seeing a
shirtless thor waltz across the screen
but for the actor himself he did not
want to have a repeat of that in
ragnarok but what about in dark world
well he didn't have a problem going
shirtless for that film because he was
feeling top physical peakness from the
gym enough from us let's listen to what
chris had to say during an interview
this time around there wasn't one in the
script which i was really happy about
and then tychus said no i think we need
a shirt off scene i was like uh no we've
done that don't make me do it again
number 14. having a bad handle on your
superhero weapon can prove to cause
injury chris hemsworth may have had a
little too much liberty with his hammer
swings during the fight with hulk in
ragnarok and that case proved to be
destructive on that poor guy's noggin i
think i probably did more damage to
myself just kind of swinging the big
thing around
the way he recalled the situation or at
least remembers it is that when fighting
cgi you have to make a definitive choice
in where you're swinging do you think he
might have believed the hulk was on top
of his head or something
number 15 if one person in the mcu could
get away with slapping a literal demigod
it would have to be jane this scene was
a serious one for chris and natalie yet
natalie may have had more fun with it
than you'd think maybe i just wanted to
keep doing it over and over again
and i was intentionally messing up doing
multiple takes of the same slap seems a
little extra at first glance but being
that she is a whole foot smaller than
hemsworth makes for a hard slapping
angle for sure these were no contact
smacks but for chris it must have been a
little annoying to keep jerking your
head around
this goes to show that even the biggest
hollywood productions cut corners and
film at best buy parking lots from time
to time but this kind of filmmaking
hustle really created memorable moments
for this cast the favorite scenes
definitely outweighed the least favorite
and if they had a good time making it we
really had a great time watching it what
was your favorite scene from thor love
and thunder if it's that scene we won't
judge let us know in the comments